um and then 2020 you think it was stolen  yeah from trump for sure and what makes  you believe that  i just i believe it i when i registered  for here in austin the register in  austin texas man when  i was uh changing states and she was  laughing at me like a week and a half  before the election going haha this  election has already been decided i was  in the car i had a witness i'm a  caregiver i was driving  do you think she just meant since biden  was so ahead in the polls no he was not  ahead without polls and no  i mean  because i bet money was somebody that  biden will win but it wasn't because i  had inside information  i don't have inside information it's  just a feeling just a feeling  and and just with the comment i mean  just walk around walk around walk around  the people walk around